هل على العالم ان يجهز كماماته مره اخرى
سؤال يدور في بالي منظمه الصحه العالميه
حاليا فلسطينيون ليسوا وحدهم يعيشون حاله
خوف بسبب العوده الشرسه لفيروس كورونا
وانما العالم اجمع دول كثيره على راسها
الهند في اسيا والمانيا في اوروبا وغيرها
بدات بالفعل باتخادي الاجراءات احترازيه
تحسبا لموجه جديده تمتد من الصين التي خرج
منها اول مصاب بالفيروس قبل حوالي ثلاثه
اعوام السلطات في الصين دافعت بالفرق
الطبيه لزياره المنازل وتقديم مبالغ ماليه
للمسنين الذين تجاوزت اعمارهم 60 عاما
وذلك مقابل الموافقه على تناول لقاح كرونه
وبينما تحاول الصين لذلك منعتزايد عدد
الاصابات بالفيروس يسود القلق وسط المسنين
اذا الحمى والجلطات الدمويه واثار
الجانبيه الاخرى التي قد ترافق الاصابه
بالفايروس الاصابات في الصين ضاعفت المخا
حول العالم مسيلمه وانه في ظل هذه
الاصابات بكرونا ستكون هناك ملايين
الطفرات وبالتالي قد تكون واحده منها على
الاقل ذات تاثير من ناحيه العدوى الشديده
او سرعه الانتقال لذلك فان الوضع في الصين
مرشح لانتاج طفارات خطيره من الفايروس
حاجه للتحقق من الكود الصحيح عندما ناكل
بالخارج لكن لا يزال الناس بحاجه الى
الاعتناء بانفسهم وارتداء الكمامات حتى لو
كانت نتيجه الفحص الطبي ايجابيه
انا قلقه من امكانيه الاصابه بالعدوى مره
ثانيه فمن الممكن ان تصاب بالعدوى اكثر من
مره
اغلاق ليست حلا على الامد الطويل لاننا
نواجه موجه اخرى